also tonight president Trump continuing
to fulfill his promise to get rid of
burdensome regulation I signed a new
executive order directing agency to cut
out rules that will impede any economic
comeback and that's not all because the
Trump administration is also moving
ahead on plans to build the nation's
first stockpile of key drug ingredients
this is crucial now instead of having to
rely on China which as we have told you
as covered up the extent of this
outbreak along with the w-h-o prompting
by the way the president he sent a
blistering letter to the whu-oh Chief
late Monday warning there will be a
permanent funding freeze if the w-h-o
doesn't make major reforms in the next
30 days here with reactions Senator Tom
cotton his proposed legislation of ban
States from stimulus funds if they're
spending it on illegal immigrants first
the China question what we did not
realize and now we do a lot of our
medical supply chain is right out of
China now in the middle of this they
wouldn't allow any travel from China
into ohan or from Wuhan until there is a
China but they left it open to the world
then they were taking up and buying up
all the world's medical supplies and a
lot of the chemical agents that we need
for our pharmaceuticals we're relying on
them for that's got a stop senator yeah
unfortunately Sean it's a tragic irony
that the country that unleashed this
pandemic on the world also controls many
of the most basic pharmaceutical
ingredients for the United States that
does have to stop I've got legislation
that would give incentives to build more
manufacturing capacity right here in the
United States and ultimately ban the
import of pharmaceuticals from China
many of which are adulterated to begin
with I also commend the president for
moving forward quickly with what
pharmaceutical manufacturing capacity we
have here in the United States to try to
build up that stock Powell so we don't
find ourselves in this position ever
again New York Illinois New Jersey
California okay they have some of the
highest state income taxes in the entire
country now there's more waste fraud
abuse debt deficits the
are now trying to get people like
yourself and people in red states that
elect responsible politicians that don't
tax and spend to death to bail their
mouths that means bail out their
stupidity now you talk about illegal
immigration how much is that costing the
state of California every year the state
of New York every year a lot of money
you're saying nobody should get any
money unless they get rid of these
policies yeah that's right Shawn we
shouldn't be spending hard-earned
taxpayer dollars on illegal immigrants a
time when 35 million Americans are out
of work if we're gonna be giving relief
checks to those people who are out of
work we need to focus on American
citizens not illegal immigrants all
right senator great job thank you for
what you do